- What makes a superhero a superhero?
That's a hard question.
- Superheros are people
who look out for others.
- The fact that they never give up,
always just in favor of justice.
- Owning up to things
that you're afraid of?
- I think heroes can come
in all shapes and forms
and it's really about owning who you are,
standing up for what you believe in.
(upbeat music)
- Today we are recreating
iconic superhero moments.
We specifically are going
to be doing the famous
upside-down kiss between
Peter Parker and Mary Jane.
- I honestly think it's
one of the most iconic
superhero scenes of all time.
- Probably one of the most
iconic kisses in movie history.
- Today I'm going to be recreating
the iconic Superman photo.
Superman has this very iconic,
classic, all American look.
I'm excited to kind of put a flip on it.
- The image that we are recreating today
is Wolverine coming out of the tank,
and just so fucking angry.
I am so excited to do this piece because
as a trans-person, it
is exactly how I felt
when I was able to be myself,
and to just be 100% happy
in my own fucking body and no
one gets to take that from me.
- All right, let's take these photos.
- One, two, three.
Your hand is up, not like this.
- Aaaaaahhhhhhhh!
- [Macey] Yeah, better.
- So I'm getting ready to recreate this
Christopher Reeves Superman photo.
It's in Superman three,
right after Superman fights
Negative Superman.
- So we're filming this in a studio.
We're going to put in the
background after the fact.
- I'm wearing this suit
and it has this, like,
beige skin, so it's
like built in whiteness.
Unfortunately, you get
used to the fact that
the world is made for white people.
And they don't often consider that
some people are not this shade.
I feel like seeing Superman as a black man
is important to put that image out there
that anybody can be Superman.
And Superman represents so
many different types of people.
- [Macey] One, two, three.
- Cool!
- Yeah.
- Ooh, I really like that one.
(synthesizer music)
- So we're having a very
serious issue right now.
It turns out that the
- I don't think so. (laughing)
Spider-man costume we got,
the mask is attached
to the body.
So we can't actually do the lifting up
that we need for the photo.
- Yeah, I think it works, right?
- Originally I thought that I was actually
gonna be upside-down,
but we're going to get
two separate images of us kissing,
and then in photo shop combine them.
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] This looks a lot
more romantic in the movie.
- [Macey] Open your
mouth a little bit, Yeah.
- I think Hollywood
gets in this rut of just
churning out the same thing
over and over and over again.
Something as simple as
changing the gender,
the sexuality, or the
race of your character
can lead you to create different stories.
And that's what people want.
- It looked good.
- All right. We did it.
- Great job.
- U got it?
- Yeah.
- All these movies are
about overcoming adversity.
It's about being shunned
by society and having to
be yourself regardless
of what people think.
And that is all what queer people
have to go through every single day.
- One, two, three. Yep.
- My favorite superhero is Wolverine.
As a trans-person, I
wanted to be something
just as masculine as Wolverine.
- They shouldn't go lower than,
like a little bit past your armpit.
- I feel pretty good.
I mean, it's cool that
these are real metal claws.
I wasn't expecting that.
They're hella heavy.
Something that's really important to me is
every time that I see
Wolverine wearing his dogtags,
reminds me of my struggles in the military
as a trans-person.
It felt really cool seeing
the pictures afterwards.
I can't wait to see
what the end result is.
(synthesizer music)
The shoot was pretty freaking awesome.
Growing up, I never thought I would
do a photo shoot of Wolverine.
It's like, for Halloween,
I always wanted that
Wolverine costume but I knew
that I could never have it.
If there was a lot more
diversity in superhero movies
I would have had a different childhood.
I think that I wouldn't
have struggled so much
with myself and my identity.
I'm keeping these, by the way. (laughing)
- It is really cool to
be wearing this suit
and actually looking in the
mirror and seeing myself
looking like Spider-man.
If someone asked me,
"What makes Spider-man,
Spider-man," I'd think his intelligence.
I'd think his courage,
his passion, his love.
I don't think his whiteness
or his straightness.
I don't think that's
essential to who he is.
- Through talking about
the idea of Superman
and kind of how he represents this
ideal, all-American citizen.
And then kind of relating that to how,
in today's terms, anyone
can be that ideal citizen.
Who cares if he's a gay black man?
If you're burning in a
building, Superman is still
gonna swoop in and save the day.
Go be a hero.
You don't have to wear a cape.
Sometimes you can just
wear drag. (laughing)
- People want to see themselves in movies.
They want to see themselves as heroes.
So let's make more of
an effort to represent
more people in society.
So if a little gay kid is growing up,
they can see themselves represented.
And you know, they can aspire
to be a hero themselves.
Tss. Tss.
(one clap)
- [Director] Cut.
(upbeat heroic music)